after originating in Asia reaching
Europe and northern America kovat 19 is
now quickly spreading across the African
continent over the weekend the
Democratic Republic of Congo registered
its first death from the virus now the
country has closed its borders and
declared a state of emergency
president Felix chickadee says the
country is at war with an invisible
adversary public life has been suspended
and the country has gone into lockdown
closing bars and restaurants and now
most flights to and from Kinshasa are
banned in this kovat 19 special we're
looking at how African countries are
preparing for the upcoming challenge on
their already vulnerable health care
systems I'm Janell de millau on thanks
for joining us coronavirus is sweeping
across africa but the true number of
cases is unknown as mass testing has not
yet been ruled out here's some of the
latest information we have for you the
number of confirmed cases in Africa shot
past the 2000 mark on Wednesday now the
majority of the continents 54 countries
have registered infections Ivory Coast
and Senegal have both declared states of
emergency and South Africa will begin a
lockdown starting Thursday joining us
from a Brazzaville in the republic of
congo is michelle yow he's the program
manager for emergency response at the
World Health Organization in Africa also
here is Al Edwards he's a professor and
immunologist at Reading University
welcome to you both Michelle I'll start
with you what sort of advisory has the
WH o given Africa if any the Advisory
it's in fact we went through different
step the first step is for around a
containment phase is early detection to
prevent local transmission as much as
possible so this helped our trying to
detect the initial cases now that we are
experiencing local transmission we have
it in more than three
in countries in Africa now the next step
is how to scale up quickly to be able to
contain the actual situation and also to
start preparing for the mitigation phase
mitigation phase is equivalent to wide
community spread that can easily over
stretch the health services like what we
are seeing now in the European countries
now biologists are also predicting that
African countries will experience their
peak number of infections this summer
now how prepared would you say the
continent is you spoke of upscaling the
capacities Michelle I would say that the
first step culture is perform quite well
by detecting the sporadic cases that
were imported in Africa but for the next
step is where we need to mobilize more
and we need more effort we need also
more support in most of the African
countries because it is a step that they
will have to deal with hundreds of
people needing intensive health care
while in the actual system in many
African and facilities you don't have
such capacity so they need to think
about how to scale up with for temporary
treatment structures how to get access
to oxygen provider and also respiratory
machine how to get access to protective
equipment so at this level countries are
less prepared because they are lacking
these resources most of them have
develop a preparedness and response plan
but the supply chain for example is one
of the major challenge to fulfill this
part that is actually urgent because we
are moving toward the white
contamination in many countries already
now Michelle spoke there of wide
contamination do you all see the crisis
in Africa reaching a similar level to
what we're seeing here and
how would that look like I think I think
that you know that's that's what we've
you know I've been thinking about
exactly that since way back you know
when we were hearing about the outbreak
first of all in wuhan in China I think
one positive is I think that much work
has gone on to try and expand for
example diagnostic testing services
across Africa and we've learnt a great
deal from programs to tackle big
infection hazards such as HIV and
malaria so for example simple rapid
testing technology is now relatively
quick and appropriate to drawl out so we
have these sorts of tests here which can
be done without a laboratory they're not
perfect but they're very easy to scale
out what I'm hoping is that what we've
learnt from those kinds of activities
those kinds of Public Health activities
will help to deal with early
identification and early containment in
these states but it is a huge problem
given that we can't contain outbreaks
very effectively in Europe I think it'll
be the same in any other country across
the world now testing of course a
important part of the response to the
corona virus Michelle would you say that
people are taking the gravity of the
situation
there in Africa seriously I think most
of the national authorities are taking
it seriously if we look at all the state
of emergency declaration that we will
start to record in many African
countries they are taking in seriously
the next step is really for the whole
population and I'm not sure that they
have this level of awareness as well as
I'll take taking it seriously in most of
the African communities there is a lot
of rumors going around including means
for for treatment so there is a work to
be done and from what we learned from
Ebola is that communities need to be
fully on board and for
they need to have appropriate
information to increase awareness but
they need to be fully engaged for them
to play a role if we have a
community-wide transmission is the
community behavior that will impact on
the way the disease will spread faster
within this community and I think
learning from Europe is time now to take
some of the measures public health
measures with full engagement of the
community to at least slow down the
spread and the objective is to flatten
the an eventual peak that will actually
a law may control with the existing
capacities should African countries go
into lockdown we've been asked this a
lot one of the problems that was trying
to give a definitive answer to the
question of whether African countries
should be locking down is that the
situation is just so unprecedented we're
having to interpret data as it
progresses we'll only really know what
measures work best after the pandemic is
over and we can compare what different
countries did and when they did it and
how that affected infection rates and
how it affected mortality what we do
know is that even though model shows
stringent social distancing measures can
help slow the speed of the spread of
this disease
they won't stop it on their own
containment measures like lock downs
also have a huge economic and social
price tag so there's no real clear
advise on one country should Institute
them but I'm pretty certain we're going
to see more of them in the coming days
in Africa as well could saw scope to
mutate quickly and reinfect people who
already had it like old viruses source
code - evolves over time collecting
mutations from generation to generation
we haven't been studying it for very
long but what we've seen so far
indicates that it's evolving more slowly
than for example flu viruses do and and
that's a positive thing flu viruses
mutate so quickly that we have to come
up with new vaccines for them every year
the question of reinfection after you've
already had cope at 19 months this kind
of still up in the air if SARS Cove 2 is
similar
to coronaviruses from the same family
that we also catch like like the viruses
that cause colds then we will develop at
least some immunity but we don't know
yet if it'll be permanent or how long it
might last can mosquitoes spread the
virus no the virus is pretty clearly not
transmitted by a blood transmission was
one of the first things that scientists
looked into after the outbreak began
they examined a range of possible ways
that it could be given to others whether
active virus can be found in blood or a
urine or stool or saliva what they
discovered is that although the virus
can be detected in the blood there's no
evidence at all that it could be
transmitted by a mosquito bite so you
don't need to worry about catching it
that way does drinking liquids regularly
prevent me from catching the virus this
is one of those really insidious myths
because it sounds pretty logical right
in fact the first person who told me
about it and sent me it's something when
this was making its rounds on the
internet a couple of weeks ago was a
doctor unfortunately it's not true
although it sounds really like a great
idea washing all those nasty viruses
down into your stomach where they can be
destroyed by the acid it unfortunately
doesn't work that way sipping water
every couple of minutes is not going to
prevent you from getting Co vat19 the
only health benefit that sipping that
water is going to have is to help you
keep hydrated now around the world
celebrities have inundated us with their
song and dance numbers often from home
and with mixed reception but Ugandan
musician turned politician Bobby wine
has seen his own take widely shared it's
a music video reminding everyone about
how to curb the spread of the corona
virus wash your hands and keep your
distance have a listen
[Music]
[Music]
Bobby wine there but we're now joined by
our correspondent joy Doreen Bharat
she's standing by for us in Nairobi
Kenya
joy we just listen to Bobby wines wrap /
public service message there for us what
sort of role do pop culture and social
media have in getting the word out a lot
actually because when we look at the
African demographics at the moment a big
population happen to fall between the
ages of 35 going down and this is where
the major concern is for a lot of people
who right now are focusing on making
sure that the young people get the
message because the older generation at
the moment does not have access to
technology on a large scale and they are
or happen to be the most vulnerable
demographic when it comes to the spread
of the corona virus or kovat 19 so
social media and pop culture is playing
a humungous role in spreading the
message to most of the young people on
the African continent and in Kenya and
Uganda as well particularly so young
people acting as multipliers of
the message there now that message
itself it seems quite simple wash your
hands stay home but neither of those
things are easy for everyone indeed
access to water is not readily available
to millions of people around the African
continent and
that in itself is a challenge especially
in the informal settlements in a lot of
areas the rural parts of Africa per se
in Kenya today what the government is
trying to do is ask the water suppliers
to be a little bit lenient with their
customers not push up their bills and
also do not switch off their water
connections in a bid to help people
flatten the curve of the corona virus
spread that water will be readily
available to the people and that even
though they might be having a race
they're still going to be able to wash
their hands and maybe take care of that
problem at a later date and also the
government has tried as much as possible
to go to areas where there is not enough
access to water to sensitize them and
also provide water where necessary thank
you very much our correspondent a joy
Doreen birra there for us in Nairobi